how many films have you helped get onto
Netflix
I believe it's five to date most of my
films that have gone on the Netflix have
gone through Distributors who then got
into Netflix in terms of directly I
believe it's five
how about this year I know we're early
in the year oh yeah none this year none
this year okay okay what's the most
recent film you got onto Netflix most
recent I'm trying to think if there's
something after Tinker that got onto
Netflix there's a film called a kind of
Lo-Fi sci-fi film called tinker
I believe that was the last one
was that the one where she was a
personal assistant to an insane writer
oh okay because that looked good no
she's Crawford who's in it okay what are
the advantages of a filmmaker getting
their movie on Netflix
um
several things
um
you know if first of all if you're
beloved by Netflix and they want to
bring you into the fold in terms of
making films
um you know one of the few companies
that can just you know
say yes very quickly and finance your
your movie
um there's a lot of things that come
with that but you know they're they're
definitely you know they've got a lot of
money to spend on production
um
you know the bragging rights are pretty
huge
um I think that's what you know film and
it's it's a way some people can see
movies very easily everybody doesn't
mind paying the subscription fee no one
has to get out their wallet and pay rent
it for four dollars
um so you can
tell the world about it and everybody
can watch it you know fairly easily
um so I think that's probably the two
main reasons that filmmakers want to be
on Netflix
did they have would you say their their
recommendations
are one of the best in terms of you know
giving you similar titles
so that your movie will be seen
you know by other movie you know like if
I'm clicking on one then it's just it's
it's so well sort of the algorithm is so
personalized yeah
um yeah I've seen I you know I think
that
um
I I don't think I've ever so my films
have been very indie
and and not Netflix or you know uh
produced
and so I think their heart they're hard
to find unless you're told about it
at the end of the day
um and perhaps like with in the case of
Tinker if you're uh you love indie film
and and sci-fi
um I'm not I'm not sure even with all
the content they have now if you wish if
that film would show up unless you typed
it in and found it that way so
I think it's still hard even to get
visibility
on Netflix
um with an indie unless you're you know
something of theirs that got a lot more
promotion than something they acquired
from a distributor
you think that was probably much
different a few years back before they
started producing their own content oh
yeah
yeah these not to produce movies so they
you know the everything was
um
other people's content Studio content
Disney movies
um
[Music]
um
unless yeah unless um and and no Netflix
originals you know at first so yeah
definitely a lot easier
any disadvantages
being on Netflix
um I depend on your expectations and
what you want I don't I don't think so
um
you know they're they're usually paying
a license fee for the right to do it so
you know what you're getting going in
um
it's a badge of honor these days to say
you're you've got to film on Netflix
um
you know I think some clients if they're
staring at a at a
um a minimal offer from Netflix versus
someone who wanted to put the film in 10
theaters
you know they have to choose a path
and depending on what they want out of
the film they might choose the
theatrical path because they just want
that kind of treatment
um
but there have been some deals like um I
currently negotiate a deal with a
different streamer
where we sold the streamer
um a pay window they're going to take it
they're paying a license fee and another
distributor is going to come in and take
all the other rights and assume that
contract
so they're going to do the theatrical do
the transactional video then it's going
to go to that streamer that bought the
film and then go to
um other other platforms later
um
and the same distributor was going to
pay a lot less
beforehand when they didn't know about
the the TV deal
so they got their cake their cake and
they eat it too so to speak because they
got
um the I can't say the name yet but the
the cable deal that they're getting and
they're getting someone to take it out
on 10 screens theatrically so
that's a win-win in that case
what are the pathways to getting a film
on Netflix these days
so there's there's pitching into the
originals division to see if it's say
something they want to take on directly
from the filmmaker or you can be with a
distributor who then after they take it
out on transactional VOD will then try
to pitch it to Netflix at the same time
they might pitch HBO Hulu and other
streamers to see if they want to take it
usually 90 to 120 days after the start
of the transactional video window
so there's really two paths there's
either directly we can sell it directly
or through a distributor as a window
later on
and cannot me as an individual just
contact Netflix could concise just send
them a letter and my experience is not
really
um
um just from
that's not to prohibit anybody from
trying or who knows if you've got the
right Moxie to get in the door right
um but um my experience is that
filmmakers come to me have tried have
not been able to get someone to watch it
so it's similar to what you were talking
about with the the need for a producer
rep in that some doors are closed yeah
some doors are open maybe they shouldn't
be but the ones that are closed
sometimes there's reasons and then you
you do those might actually be the best
ones to try absolutely yeah okay
interesting so if if they know someone
or if um the distributor that they've
gone with has access
that's usually how it's done yeah or
smaller yeah exactly
and do most Distributors promise that or
they entertain it but they don't promise
it
um both
um there's some Distributors that that
say
um there's some Distributors that that
will say yes we're going to pitch it to
Netflix and HBO Etc
um that same distributor might also want
to film but say hey we want it but we're
probably not going to be able to make a
deal with HBO or Netflix if they're
being honest
um
there are some Distributors that
um on the lower side of the spectrum
that don't even try because they don't
have the relationships they're smaller
Distributors that just can't that take
films out to the transactional vosd
space and the advertising video space
but don't have the relationships to make
a deal with Netflix or Hulu Etc
um
and then there are some Distributors
that kind of pretend they have the
relationship and just say that they can
pitch them and really can't
how does an indie filmmaker get a
Netflix original
well the so there's kind of two ways one
is if you've somehow managed to pitch it
to Netflix and they want to make it with
you normally to get that pitch you've
got to be going in with someone who's
made a film with them before
they and most
hollywood-based
Distributors and just don't have an open
door policy for anybody to come in and
Pitch anything most of them including
Netflix make films with
the production companies that are owned
by
stars or just producers that have been
making films for a long time
and so your most likely path is getting
involved with one of them getting
somehow getting them to look at your
material and having them want to make it
and take it in to get financing from
Netflix
um
that's one way the other way is to pitch
it to Netflix
to the original Department have them
like what you already made
and decide hey we'll we'll make it we'll
turn into an original
it seems like they're taking a lot of or
they're making a lot of adaptations
Netflix or at least the ones I've been
watching are yeah yeah they make all
different kinds of content now it's uh
from reality to documentaries and
they're you know they're
they analyze their the metrics they have
to see what their viewers want dictates
you know what they make
um and who they make films with
yeah you know I've suggested several
films because you know they have this
email thing that you can just put in
would you like to you know a title we
don't have that you'd like to see and
right unfortunately I haven't seen them
up there but you know I keep trying and
I have no personal investment in it I
just want to see it on there but um do
you ever
recommend a filmmaker go with just a
strict Netflix deal rather than
theatrical
[Music]
um
um you know
I'm usually following the lead of the
filmmaker on that and trying to see what
their goals are and try to advise them
according to what the what they want
and I can point out
depending on what's being offered
what I what I subjectively think is the
best math monetarily
as in terms of maximizing the value was
the best bet
um but if you want a certain kind of
exposure what's the other you know
what's the other mean because there's
all levels of theatrical
um from one screen to 10 screens to 100
screens you know so it kind of depends
on what's being proffered
um
um and kind of depends on what I think
the filmmaker you know wants out of it
at the end of the day
when you see exposure are they also
considering future projects down the
line getting their name out there maybe
is more important than getting someone
to see movie A it's about maybe movie b
or c that's coming yeah I find you know
most filmmakers have
competing goals
um that aren't necessarily at odds with
each other but you know many of them
will say well it's most important for me
to get my money back for my investors
but it's also just as important for me
to make my get my next project off the
ground
um so I've really declared that they've
got two important most important things
you know at the day
um
I'd say and then it kind of depends
because there are some people who have
financed their own thing so they have
kind of they definitely have both things
in mind there's some people I'm dealing
with where they have there's the
executive producer that I never meet
and but they're in control of the
property and they're much more concerned
about
you know that going on to the next thing
then maybe their executive producer is
so you know and then I get sometimes the
executive producer is part of the
discussion so they're having to pay
attention to that person and and really
the goal is monetization I find that
though usually the best situation for
exposure matches the best
[Music]
um
um path for monetization is usually not
um
it's pretty rare to have that
um
Netflix offer versus
semi-wide theatrical rethink while the
money's kind of equal
the exposure is kind of equal
it's usually usually someone you know is
is putting up something that's a lot
better than everybody else